riding high with the success of Snow
White and Pinocchio it's interesting
that Disney decide to do something 100%
different for their third film Fantasia
doesn't have a narrative story pill it
doesn't even have any dialogue apart
from the host it's just an experiment of
taking classical music and combining it
with great Disney animation it's not one
story is several stories a half the time
they're not even really stories the
opening is just a collection of abstract
imagery that goes along with the music
like what your mind might be thinking
when hearing it for the first time and I
friggin love it it's not just one my
favorite Disney films it's one of my
favorite films period remember what I
was saying before about emotional
simplicity you could argue that this is
the film that masters it whereas I
described both Snow White and Pinocchio
as emotional stories this is what I like
to call an emotional experience it's not
based on narrative as much as moments
and life is made up a very unique moment
so I don't think there's really any
problem in putting them together in a
movie especially they do get an
emotional response sometimes it creates
a confusing response like the one with
the dinosaurs I never know how to feel
watching that sometimes they're
threatening sometimes they're cute and
then through the course of the piece
they're just gone I remember as a kid I
had no idea what to think about it's
just sort of something that happened and
you draw your own conclusions some
definitely do have a flowing narrative
like the most famous one The Sorcerer's
Apprentice this is actually how the film
came about Disney just want to make this
short with Mickey Mouse as a magician
but as the expenses for it got bigger
and bigger they finally just shrugged
and said hey while we do a couple of
these just turn into a flick the result
is some booming fantastic music with
some booming fantastic animation I think
sometimes just the falling of leaves can
be so much more powerful than the
emotional conflict that a character is
going through if the film is done right
it can suck you into something so simple
and yet so oddly profound and Disney
animators were great at that they could
find the ballet the movement the music
anything that was poetic in well really
anything even just the changing of
seasons
I stayed this before but my absolute
favorite is the ending both a Night on
Bald Mountain and the Ave Maria even if
you don't have a religious background
just the very basic emotional
levels they have here a really high the
contrast in putting these two together
is just brilliant and the belief in
something much darker than you can
imagine or more inspiring than you can
imagine is definitely there Disney want
to do a lot more of these and have this
be a continuing film series but sadly
the film didn't make the money that it
needed oh it made a lot of money it was
like the second or third highest
grossing film that year but it didn't
matter the film cost a fortune to make
him financially it just didn't make
sense to make anymore
we did make one sequel years later
though we'll get to that when we come
around to it for this film though
Fantasia is a powerhouse of art in fact
it's actually like going to an art
museum except with motion and music as
you can imagine though it's not as gerd
for kids as the other Disney things
there's nothing really troubling or bad
about it that kids can't watch I
remember watching Bald Mountain find
when I was younger but with the
exception maybe Sorcerer's Apprentice
there's nothing here that's immediately
geared towards them this was the
animated Disney film almost strictly for
adults and while kids could watch it it
wasn't exactly their film it was more
for the grown-ups and those who loved it
really loved it and it still continues
to be one of my films